[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding [music] health
or income. As an empowered individual,
you do have options available. We are
honored [music] to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor [music] of Science in Plant and
soil sciences, doctor of veterary
medicine, four post-docctorates in
pathology, naturopathic doctor.
All right, let's open up that waiting
room. Open up the doors actually to the
Zoom meeting. Hello everybody. My name
is Becca Dukes. I am so excited to have
you here with us. Welcome, welcome. If
you're here live with us, make sure you
have that chat open as we have Marilyn
and Phyllis both gonna do some tag
teaming and making sure that you get all
of the information in black and white so
that you can well they help you take
notes. So if you can't write as fast as
our speaker, then at least they can type
faster and you can get all the
information you need there. So I am
Becca Jukes. I'm excited to be here as
folks here on this program. We create a
space where education, experience, and
lived wisdom come together, mind, body,
and spirit. And as the director of
student services for the Institute of
Holistic Health, a certified holistic
health coach myself, and also a
certified naturopathic practitioner, I'm
excited to be able to produce and bring
to you a resource that empowers you, an
individual. So whether you're a coach or
whether you're just somebody seeking
information, this program is for you.
So, if you have any questions and
somebody invited you to this program,
you want to make sure that you get back
with them, they are your number one
point of contact and they cared enough
about you to share this information.
Return the favor, tell them thank you,
and again, they're going to be your
first point of contact. Now, if you
found us on your own and you have never
spoken with anybody about any of the
products that we mentioned on this
program, then we do have a call team
standing by to help at 855-9493377.
Again, 855-9493377.
And if you have any questions about the
content of this program, like if we
offer something and you would want to
get a copy of it, questions
dailywithdoc.com.
Again, that's questions with an s on the
end at dailywithdoc.com.
Well, folks, today we tr are we're just
truly honored as we have an
extraordinary guest, somebody that I
love and appreciate and respect dearly,
and that is Dr. Joanne Conaway. So, Dr.
Joanne Conaway, she is a ret retired
United States Air Force nurse, having
served with dedication, discipline, deep
compassion in some of the most demanding
environments imaginable. Folks,
following her military career, she
continued her lifelong calling to heal
as a naturopathic doctor focusing on
root cause wellness, which is what this
program is all about, balance, and
supporting the body's innate ability to
restore and regulate itself. Today's
conversation takes a takes a powerful
and timely turn as we explore
how we can evict those little critters
that may be residing within our body.
Now, it used to be called the full moon
cleanse, but it has been changed as a
dynamic duo parasite cleanse protocol.
We're going to be going through that
protocol. She's going to be explaining
the ins and outs of it and exactly why
and how they put this program together.
So, this conversation is about
reclaiming your health, working in
rhythm with the body, and making space
for true renewal. Folks, if you have any
questions again and you want any
information that is being offered
like your own personal, you got to do it
exactly the way it's written protocol.
You can request that by emailing
questions dailywithdoc.com.
So folks, grab your coffee, settle in
and join us for an enlightening
discussion as we have Dr. Joanne
Conaway. Hello Dr. Conaway. Thank you so
much. I think beginning of the year,
people are wanting to make changes and I
can't think of a better time to really
dig into
this topic today. Thank you. Thank you.
Well, I'm happy to be here and thank you
so much for having me. And you know,
you're absolutely right. This time of
year is when people want to make
changes. This time of year is for
whatever reason, it doesn't happen in
June. It doesn't happen in September,
but it happens in January. People make
the decision they want to start over.
They want to take care of themselves. So
today, what we're going to talk about
is a problem that a lot of people don't
recognize as being so significant in
this country. Excuse me. When we talk
about parasites, for so many years
working in the medical field, parasites
were something that occurred when people
had been to a third world country.
Perhaps they had been someplace else.
Maybe they drank the water. Maybe they
ate fish that wasn't cooked. Maybe they
swam in streams. You know, I used to
watch a show on TV and I think it's
still on. And the title of it was the
monster inside me or the monster within
me. I can't remember what, but I found
it very fascinating because it was
people who had had longterm
protracted symptoms that could not be
readily identified by mainstream
medicine. Docs would treat the symptoms
for sometimes several years and never
finding the root cause until somebody
would make the decision that maybe we
should go ahead and call in a tropical
medicine doc and see if we've got
anything here. And so it was interesting
watching that show because so oftentimes
once again they would talk about people
who had had symptoms for years and
doctors would work with the symptoms
never identifying the root cause right
up until they finally made the decision
that this person needs to go for
psychiatric help because we can't deal
with these symptoms. These symptoms are
not going away. They're not getting
better. What is it about this person
that is driving this behavior? And then,
as I said, finally a tropical medicine
doc would step in and they would
identify parasites. They would treat for
the parasites and lo and behold, the
symptoms would get better, the people
would get better. So, I found it
fascinating because, as I said,
throughout my entire career in nursing,
if a person had parasites, it was always
assumed they had been out of this
country. The assumption was they had
been to a third world country and that's
how they had contracted parasites
because heaven forbid they would
contract parasites in the United States.
But now if you look at the research
that's out there, there are some
researchers that say 85% of us have
parasites. There are researchers that
say if you're walking, talking, taking
nutrition, you have parasites. So
literally,
so often times when we talk about
parasites, people don't like to think
about it. They don't like to talk about
it. They throw their hands in the air
and say, "That could never happen to me.
I mean, I have a really clean house and
I use antibacterial soap and you know,
all of those things." But what we know
is parasites come to us by various
different means. And one of the biggies
is
produce coming in from all over the
world. When we talk about how we eat the
standard American diet, the standard
American diet or the SAD diet as we have
it is a diet that's loaded with produce
and other things that are imported from
all over the world. Often times these
critters just hitchhike into our food
supply by way of these foods that are
delivered from all different parts of
the world. So that's one of the ways we
get parasites. Interestingly enough,
there have been parasites found in some
municipal water supplies. Not a pleasant
thing to think about. Certainly, if
people are drinking from the faucet,
which I never recommend, but if people
are drinking from the faucet, often
times they can encounter various
different bacteria and things in that
water, but there have been instances
where parasites have actually been
found. Now, one of the other ways, and
this is a way that a lot of people are
exposed to parasites that is away from
food, okay? I mean, normally when we
talk about food, I know that I do a
parasite cleanse periodically because I
like sushi. I like cevichi. I like those
things that are not thoroughly cooked. I
know that I'm probably exposing myself
to parasites and from my perspective,
better out than in. Okay. But our pets
very readily share their parasites. And
often times people don't think about it.
But a good example is if you have an
animal, most people who have pets, you
know that your vet says you really need
to worm your pets at least twice a year.
And that's because pets get into
everything. And no matter what, they are
prone to carrying parasites. and sharing
parasites. Now, how do our pets share
our parasites with us? Well,
a pet defecates in the yard, even if
you're fidious about cleaning it up. If
you walk bare barefoot through the yard
and you have any type of an open sore on
your foot, you're likely to be able to
get parasites from what got left behind.
The other thing, and a lot of people
don't like me talking about this, but
the other way that they share their
parasites, is when they do those little
puppy kisses, when animals lick your
legs or lick your feet or lick your
cheeks, they can share their parasites
with you that way. If you allow your pet
to sleep on your bed or on your
furniture,
they can share their parasites in that
way. So, I'm always very cautious
when I work with people because people
don't want to hear that, you know, and
people who have dogs oftentimes they
have dogs, their loving little dog
sleeps with them all night or, you know,
their loving little cat sleeps with them
all night. But they you have to
understand that you're taking a risk.
You're taking a risk of exposure to
parasites. Now when we talk about that
there are different ways that we can
deal with parasites in animals that
doesn't mean you have to have in fact my
animals get the GI cleanse every single
day and they have yet to have parasites
for that reason but I still don't allow
them to sleep with me in the bed and I
still don't allow them up in the
furniture and I still don't allow them
to lick my face and lick my feet because
I know that there's a likelihood hood
that they have parasites and they can
share their parasites. So those are a
few different ways that parasites can
come to us. And so when you think about
it like that and think about the fact
that we are for the most part all
exposed to produce coming in from other
countries. We are for the most part all
exposed to water in some way. Oftentimes
we have pets. There are various
different ways they can come to us. And
so that's one of the reasons why
research now says 85% of us have
parasites. And as I've said, there are
some researchers that say 100% of us
have parasites. So given that, a lot of
people, first of all, don't want to hear
it. They get freaked out when you say to
them, "Well, you may have parasites."
But let's think about that for just a
minute. It is in some ways a frightening
consideration to think that I might have
something else growing inside me.
Something else that has made the
decision that I am where they want to be
and they are taking from me. That whole
thought kind of freaks you out. However,
given that that might be the case, why
wouldn't somebody say, "Hey, let's just
do a parasite cleanse and be done with
it." Now, this new parasite cleanse that
we have, it's not actually new. It's
just the process is a little bit
different than the full moon cleanse.
We've used the full moon cleanse for
many, many years, and now we're using
the dynamic duo parasite cleanse
protocol. But that cleanse protocol is a
protocol that is designed to go after
parasites. Doesn't matter what kind of
parasites. You know, when we talk about
parasites, people oftentimes will think
about things like giardia or they'll
think about tapeworms. We know that
tapeworms is a very popular parasite.
Okay? And we've heard the stories about
p tapeworms that come out of people that
are 25 inches long. And we know that
tapeworms can live inside a person for
25 years. They just continue to grow and
grow and grow. pin worms and round worms
and flukes and all of those things could
be a part of our everyday lives. And so
this particular protocol will actually
go after any and all parasites.
Now the fascinating thing is when we
talk about parasites, we know that there
are things like liver flukes. We know
that many parasites impact the
gastrointestinal system. But parasites
have also occurred in people's brains.
Now, this is not a pleasant thing to
think about and I have recently been
involved in three different situations
where these people actually had
parasites in the brain.
And unfortunately for them, they were
those people who had been treated long
term and no one could come up with
exactly what had caused the problems,
the symptoms. you know, they had
dizziness, blurred vision, um
restlessness,
headaches,
stiff necks, all kinds of symptoms, and
to the point where all three were in
fact debilitated. They could not hold a
job. They couldn't hold a job because
they couldn't get a decent night's
sleep, and they were just on disability
and suffering greatly and could not
enjoy life in any way, shape, or form.
And so when it was determined that they
had parasites in the brain, we used this
parasite cleanse and all three of them
are now holding down good jobs and
leading normally healthy lives. We just
had to get rid of the parasites. And so
I think it's important for people to
realize that they are far more prevalent
than we think. They are not just a third
world problem. And if you have symptoms
that are unexplained, if you have
symptoms that keep recurring and you
just can't seem to get rid of those
symptoms, you need to consider that it's
parasites. Now, you all know that I'm
heavy on the gut and when I work with
anybody and everybody, I start them out
with a gut protocol. It's fascinating to
me because so oftentimes what we've
learned is if we repeat the gut
protocol, sometimes that's what it takes
for people's symptoms to go away. And
we've had significant success with doing
the gut protocol once and then repeating
it in addition to the 90 nutrients, the
good food, bad food, those other things
that we know are so critically
important. But what about those people
who do that protocol twice and they
still have symptoms? What about those
people who do do that protocol twice,
but they still have skin issues? Well,
there's a likelihood that if the
protocol has not taken care of their
issue, it could well be parasites. And
when we talk about the symptoms that are
associated with parasites, it's
fascinating because so many of them can
be the same symptoms that are associated
with
having an imbalanced gut, having an
imbalanced gut microbiome. So I usually
start out with the gut protocol. Now if
a person comes to me and tells me that
they have been diagnosed with parasites,
then I immediately put them on the
parasite protocol. And the reason for
that is we're not going to be able to
affect a change and help these people
improve their wellness if they have
parasites living inside them. And so I
will in those situations start out with
the parasite protocol. But for the most
part, what I have found is people who
have all of these chronic symptoms, and
this is one of the reasons why I'm a
stickler on this, if you have someone
who has symptoms and those people are
not improving and not getting better,
then consider that it could be
parasites. Now, in my opinion, you don't
necessarily have to go and have the
parasites identified. Certainly, you can
do that. But one of the important things
to remember about that is when you go to
have testing done for parasites,
depending on when you have the testing
done, for example, as I said, a lot of
parasites impact the gastrointestinal
system. So people will submit a stool
sample and that stool sample will be
used to determine whether or not they
have parasites. Well, interestingly
enough, depending upon when the sample
was collected, there may be no
indication of parasites. And this is one
of the things that is a real drawback
for many people because they'll say,
"Oh, I had my stool tested and I didn't
have parasites."
Well, maybe not that particular specimen
on that particular day, but that does
not mean that you don't have parasites.
One of the things that we know is
parasites become very active during the
full moon. And so when I have people who
make the decision that they want to be
tested, I encourage them to collect that
stool specimen at the time of the full
moon. That's when you're going to have
the best chance for being able to
actually identify whether or not there
are parasites. But for the most part,
for me, it does not necessarily require
testing. If people have chronic
symptoms, people have chronic bloating,
people have indications that they have
some type of inflammation in the colon,
people have chronic skin issues that
they just cannot get rid of. If people
come to me like that, then I suggest
that they do this protocol. It's not
going to hurt to do the protocol.
Sometimes people may experience a die-
off reaction and we'll talk about that
in just a few minutes. But usually the
way this particular protocol is set up,
excuse me, any die- off reaction
is minimal. Most people do not have an
issue, do not have a problem. But what I
also tell people is if you're going to
do this protocol and you suspect that
you have parasites, don't be too shocked
and surprised if you see the parasites.
If you see evidence of the parasites in
the toilet, if you see evidence of the
parasites coming out through your skin,
okay, it doesn't sound pleasant, but
better out than in, right? You want to
get rid of them. So, I caution people
and tell them, don't get so upset if you
see that these critters are leaving you.
It's better that they are leaving you.
But again, the thing I want to stress is
when people have chronic issues and
chronic problems that they just simply
cannot identify or get rid of, that's
when I consider that it may well be
parasites. Now, some people there are a
lot of people out there that say
parasites can cause all kinds of issues
and problems. I for one believe that
that's true. When we talk about
parasites, parasite, what is a parasite?
Well, parasite is something that just
kind of hitchhikes, okay? Something that
comes into you and starts living off you
and starts some of the parasites that
are gut parasites, for example, start
taking your nutrients. Sometimes people
will have issues where they are losing
weight for no identifiable reason or
they're trying to lose weight and can't
lose weight. These sometimes are
symptoms that are associated with having
parasites. And so when a person has
those long-term symptoms that they just
can't seem to recognize or identify or
mainstream medicine can't come up with
the answer, then I recommend doing the
parasite cleanse. Now, personally, I do
the parasite cleanse usually a couple of
times a year. And the reason I do is
because, as I mentioned,
I like cevichi. I like sushi, uh, steak
tartar. They are not my mainstay
everyday meals, but I do enjoy those
things periodically. And because I do, I
do recognize that I may in fact be
exposing myself to parasites. So again,
better out than in. Why not do it? It's
not going to hurt you to do it. And so I
do recommend that people do it at least
once a year. If you are someone who eats
foods like that, then perhaps it's best
to go ahead and do it twice a year and
it's not going to hurt you to do that.
Now the component parts of this
particular protocol, it's interesting
because first of all before we go any
further, does anyone have any questions?
Do you have questions that
>> it doesn't? We don't. Well, actually, we
do have a question. Um, and it goes back
to you had mentioned how you give your
animals the GI cleanse every day. Brenda
wants to know, how do you give a cat the
GI cleanse? Um, they use canned food or
do you use by the dropper?
>> How do you how would you make a cat? I
use a dropper
>> and usually for a cat, depending upon
the size of the cat, it's about four
drops, not droppers,
drops, and that should be adequate. Now,
if you have a big cat, if you have an
adult cat that weighs 10 lbs, then you
might want to up it to six, maybe eight
drops.
But my cat gets it on her food every
single day, and she has since she was a
kitten. She doesn't know any better.
That's part of her routine at night. She
just gets it dropped on her food. But
for her, she's a very small cat. So for
her, what I do is I just put four drops
on her food along with her dusting of
arthrit. And that's how she gets her
parasite cleanse. That's how she gets
the
>> So a 15 pound cat, you're looking closer
to eight drops.
>> 15 pound cat, you'd be looking at eight
drops. And eight drops should be
sufficient.
>> Excellent. Awesome. Thank you so very
much.
>> Yeah. And once again, it's drops, not
droppers. You know, that's a really
important thing.
>> When people are are first using the GI
cleanse, they've never seen it, never
used it before. They read the label and
it says droppers, and so they think
droppers. Well, no. When we're talking
about pets, and we're talking about
something that weighs no more than 15
pounds, you don't want to give them
droppers of the solution. you want to
give them drops of the solution. So,
>> excellent. Excellent. Well, please go
ahead and continue. I mean, there's
there's quite a bit to discuss and and
you had mentioned um if somebody is
anemic and there's no evidence of
bleeding,
>> correct?
>> They could have parasites
>> and depending upon the parasite, they
could have a parasite. There are
parasites who want your nutrition, but
there are parasites who attach to you
only because they want your blood. And
you know, this is another thing there.
There's a lot of research out there that
has shown that people who have chronic
anemia,
it's not because they aren't eating
properly. It's not because they're
bleeding somewhere that's identifiable.
It's because they have parasites that
are sucking their blood. And again, not
a pleasant thing to think about.
However, if that's the case, let's just
get rid of them.
I mean, that's my approach.
>> It's like an internal leech.
>> Absolutely. And that's exactly what it
is. They are actually sucking your
blood. And there's so many different
types, you know, there's so many
different types of worms. Another thing
that a lot of people don't realize is
bed bugs are parasites. And you know bed
bugs have been a considerable problem in
many parts of this country, hotels and
places like that. Bed bugs not a
pleasant thought. Okay. And this is one
of the reasons why a lot of times well
people will have chronic itchy skin and
they're not able to identify what's
causing that chronic itchy skin. It
doesn't seem to be a problem with dry
skin. and they take enough enough
essential fatty acids and they, you
know, use good body lotion and they do
all of that stuff, but their skin is
itchy. Well, when people come to me and
they have that concern, one of my first
questions is, have you stayed in a hotel
recently?
Have you been outside of your home
sleeping in a situation where you may
have picked up bed bugs? Now, I say
outside your home. The unfortunate thing
with bed bugs is if you've been in a
hotel and you've slept in a bed that has
bed bugs, those bed bugs are not only in
the bed, they're in the bed, they're in
the drapes, they're in the carpeting,
and depending upon where you put your
suitcase in that room, they're now in
your suitcase. You bring them home and
they can be a horrific problem. And so I
think it's important for people to
realize that this type of a parasite can
impact you in a very negative way as
well. And we see more and more in terms
of the research around this and devices
that will help to in fact kill the bed
bugs or collect the bed bugs or get rid
of the bed bugs. The other thing people
don't realize when we talk about
parasites, people don't oftenimes think
about ticks, but ticks are also
parasites. And when people are exposed
to ticks, if they don't deal with it and
do something about it, they can get
very, very sick. It doesn't have to be
Lyme disease, but they can get very sick
with a tick bite. I know that I have an
individual friend personally who
just for is a tick magnet. I have a
granddaughter who has become a tick
magnet. I mean, this child when she goes
out in the yard, she it's it's just
horrible. She's only two years old and
it's just awful. She's a tick magnet.
But when you are dealing with ticks like
that, this one friend that I mentioned,
whenever this person gets a tick bite,
it takes months for the evidence to go
away. And it's just this is a person who
reacts and responds to tick bites with a
raised red area that takes months to go
away. But ticks are parasites. And
again, what are ticks doing? they're
attaching to you
and taking a part of you. And so we just
have to make sure that we address tick
issues as well and recognize that they
are in fact a parasite. And this is one
of the big reasons why my animals get
the GI cleanse every single day. I know
that where I live there is constantly
a an overgrowth of ticks. if you will.
They're just there all the time. And
because of that, my animals used to have
issues bringing them home from the field
all the time. So, I just make sure that
they get the GI cleanse every single
day.
>> That's awesome. Now, we have one more
question um based on something that you
have mentioned and you had mentioned how
the parrots parasites may come out of
the skin. Nancy wants to know, do they
look like worms where on the body
they're likely to come out or other than
come out other than the stools?
Okay, it depends on the parasite. Okay,
sometimes parasites coming out of the
skin can look like little worms. I have
seen a situation where a person had
parasites in their eyes and it looked
like little worms under the whites of
their eyes and that's exactly what it
was. Okay. So, it depends on the
parasite. Um, I do ha I have had people
who have described to me looking like
little worms coming out from under the
skin and that's certainly one way the
parasites can present. oftentimes they
look like little flexcks or little bitty
bugs coming out of the skin. So it
depends on the parasite because
parasites, you know, parasites can come
into the body and unfortunately they can
come in with food and some of them elect
not to hang around in the
gastrointestinal system. They sneak out
of the gastrointestinal system and they
may take up residence in the area of a
joint for example and start causing
issues and problems in the joint. And so
it depends on the parasite, but
all kinds of descriptions,
not just in the toilet, which is, you
know,
>> Oh, absolutely. You know, I have a
client in Oregon.
Um, she does landscaping and a lot of
gardening
and she had sent me some pictures and
there was like they almost looked like
splinters coming out of her skin, but
they were moving.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> cuz she sent a little video. It was
crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> And another one in Texas where she had
it and it looked like little flexcks of
dirt.
But then I I asked her, I said, "Okay,
do a can you do a video for about 30
seconds?" And sure enough, they were
they were moving.
>> Those little flexcks of dirt were
moving. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> It's crazy. Very crazy.
>> It is. And that's why people get so
freaked out about, you know, I mean, you
don't like to think about things
crawling out of your skin, but once
again, you'd rather have them out than
in. So,
>> I absolutely agree. And, you know, we're
we're always talking about, you know,
going organic, non-GMO, grow your own
food. Well, there's microorganisms that
we want in that garden
>> and there are parasites that you want in
the garden. You know, if you're going to
get a good crop, there are parasites
that grow in the soil. And this is one
of the reasons why so many times people
who are landscapers and people who work
in the garden all the time, they just
love to feel the dirt under their feet.
Well, that's fine and dandy if your feet
are in good condition, but if you have
any broken skin or any area where a
parasite can get in, you can end up with
parasites. And that's why when I work
with people who garden a lot, myself
included, but when I work with people
who garden a lot, I make sure they
understand the importance of the fact
that parasites are necessary.
However, make sure that you realize that
you could in fact be infecting yourself
with parasites and just do a periodic
parasite cleanse.
>> Absolutely. So, um, Nancy, did you have
anything else to add to your question? I
see your hand is up.
You should be able to unmute.
>> No.
>> All right.
>> I was just wondering like where you
answered it.
>> I heard you and then I didn't.
>> Did we lose Nancy?
>> No.
>> I think we lost Nancy. Well, let's go
over. We do have a couple more hands up.
Do you want to take a couple more
questions? I definitely want to make
sure we get to the cleanse itself.
>> Okay,
we've got time for a couple more
questions.
>> Oh, fantastic. All right, Phyllis, what
question do you have for us today?
>> Uh, Dr. Conway, I have a male client. He
does have arthritis
and he he has pacific
>> he he has um persistent neck pain, I
would say, of the symptoms you
mentioned. He has a stiff neck,
persistent neck pain, um may some
insomnia, may have an inflamed gut. Now,
um he was told by a chiropractor that he
might have a vagus nerve issue, but I'm
wondering about the possibility of
parasites. Um can you comment on the
vagus nerve aspect of that and and um
would he benefit from this parasite
cleanse?
>> Okay. I find it interesting that the
chiropractor identifies it as a
potential vagus nerve issue, but what's
the chiropractor doing about that? Yeah,
I mean one of the things that we talk
about a lot um for example if people
have cardiac issues, people have atrial
fib or ventricular tacicardia,
my recommendation is to go to a
chiropractor who can do a good cervical
thoracic adjustment because oftentimes
what has happened is the Vegas nerve
gets pinched off and oftentimes when the
Vegas nerve gets pinched off people will
have issues like atrial fibrillation and
ventricular ular tacicardia and they'll
also have gut issues. Remember that the
biggest nerve is the longest nerve in
the body innervates everything in the
thoracic cavity and abdominal cavity. So
you can have all kinds of symptoms and
problems associated with the Vegas
nerve. But if this chiropractor has not
been able to deal with the Vegas nerve,
my first suggestion would be perhaps
seek out a chiropractor that's more
familiar with Vegas nerve. someone who
can do that specific type of adjustment.
But would I suggest doing the parasite
cleanse? Absolutely. And especially if
it's a situation where the person has
been trying to deal with it, working
with a chiropractor and not able to get
a good result. Let's consider that it
could be parasites.
>> Exactly. I I do believe he's been
getting those type of adjustments. So,
it seems it could be that they're not
sufficient or it is a parasite issue.
And it sounds like that's what you're
saying.
>> Okay.
>> What I always say is, you know, when
people have unresolved issues,
just do a parasite cleanse. Maybe you
don't have parasites, but the cleanse is
not going to hurt you. And if you do
have parasites, you're going to get
better. So,
>> it can it can only be helpful no matter
what.
>> Exactly.
>> All right. Thank you so much.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Awesome. Thank you so much. And Marilyn,
what question are you bringing in today?
>> I have a client too that recently said
she has seen she had a live blood scan
and she has ticks in the eyelids and her
doctors are saying it's like a sexually
transmitted disease where there's no
cure. Now, it doesn't matter where these
parasites are in the body. the GI
cleanse and and with the parasite
cleanse can get rid of it. Doesn't
matter where it is, right?
>> That's right. That's absolutely right.
>> Okay. Because she's convinced she can't
get like sexually transmitted like it's
it's in there for life because she's had
this repeated test and it continues to
stay in that eyelid.
>> Interesting.
>> I would definitely try the cleanse.
Absolutely.
>> Okay.
>> Perfect. Thank you.
My feeling is if we know that this
cleanse had worked on people who had
parasites in the brain, let's give it a
chance wherever you think you might have
parasites.
So that's my approach. Okay. So let's
talk about the cleanse for just a few
minutes. You know, we've talked about
some of the symptoms that are associated
with the potential for having parasites
in the body. Lots and lots of them.
Okay? I mean, I'm just going to run
through some of these very quickly, but
multiple food allergies. A lot of times
people have multiple food allergies and
they don't correlate those food
allergies to having parasites. Okay. Um
weakness and fatigue, itching around the
anus, especially at night. This is often
indicative of pinw worms. And oftentimes
people will come to me and this is one
of the things that they complain about
for whatever reason. They clean
themselves good after they have a bowel
movement. They make sure they shower
before they go to bed, but they still
have this itching. That is a telltale
sign of pinw worms. And so if a person
has that sign, then definitely I feel
like they need to do a parasite cleanse.
Restlessness and difficulty sleeping.
Again, this is a symptom that
unidentified problems sleeping. I don't
know why I have problems sleeping. I'm
just restless all night long. Well,
let's consider that it might be
parasites and do a parasite cleanse.
um coughing bloody sputum in some cases.
Now, that's a pretty severe indicator,
but what that tells you is you've got
very active parasites and they are
breaking down your body. So, as I've
said, there are many, many symptoms that
can be associated with parasites. So,
what do we want to do about it? Well, we
want to get them out. Parasites, once
again, parasites out, better out than
in. So when you start a parasite
cleanse, it is paramount to make sure
that the bowel is opening and
functioning properly. You want to make
sure that you don't have a situation
where you're constipated or backed up
because that is not going to facilitate
the passage of these critters. You want
them out. So, the first thing that we
recommend is that you try a product like
the Colon FX or the Slender FX Cleanse
FX just to make sure that the bowel is
open and things are moving through. Now,
if you're someone who normally has three
bowel movements every single day, it's
not an issue for you, you don't have a
problem with constipation, you don't
have a problem with diarrhea, then I
wouldn't be so concerned about that.
However, it's not going to hurt. You
know, if you're someone who has three
bowel movements every day, normally
healthy bowel movements every day, and
you don't want to do the colon effects
or the co the uh slender effects,
cleanse FX, then consider just taking an
extra dose or two of vitamin C or an
extra dose or two of magnesium,
something that's going to help to push
things through the gut. Okay? You want
the colon to be open.
So what we do is we actually
take this protocol and
the protocol is designed so that you can
either take a mixture that includes
garlic
or you can take a mixture that has the
the respiratory support from the good
herbs line which has enough garlic in it
that it will do exactly the same job.
Um, you're going to do this and you're
going to do it at the time of the full
moon. And that's one of the reasons why
when I publish the protocol, I always
make sure that I put the dates of the
full moon. Often times people get
confused. They, well, when well, when is
the full moon? So, let's just stop that
confusion right now. And so, I've put
the dates down for the full moon. But
once again, as I mentioned,
when we talk about doing the cleanse,
parasites are more active at the time of
the full moon. This is something that
has been proven over and over again. So,
let's go after them at the time of the
full moon and get it done. Okay. Now,
the other recommendation that has been
consistently made for many, many years
is the GI cleanse in us as adult humans.
I recommend that we do the GI cleanse
for the time up until the full moon. The
GI cleanse by itself every day. And I
suggest that you do it three times a day
on an empty stomach. This is something
that you want to do on an empty stomach
because what you're trying to do is
you're trying to force those little
critters out. But then at the time of
the full moon, that's when you do the
more aggressive part of the protocol.
And that more aggressive part of the
protocol will actually include using the
GI cleanse, but in addition to that, you
want to use the respiratory support or
the garlic.
and also the nerve support. Now, the
nerve support, excuse me,
[clears throat] it's interesting. Why
would you want to use nerve support?
The nerve support actually will kind of
make the critters a little more
lethargic, if you will, and that seems
to encourage them to move out more
quickly. So, in the full protocol,
you're going to see that. and I'm going
to have to resubmit that full protocol
to you back up because for some reason I
don't know what happened, but it doesn't
seem like the full protocol is together
in the printout that I sent you. So, I
will resend the print out. But again,
this should be done on the day of the
full moon and we have always said the
day before, the day after or the day
before, the day of and the day after the
full moon. But back to the GI cleanse,
depending upon when the full moon is.
Okay, so let's say we've just I we've
just recently had a full moon. Okay, I
think it was the third maybe. So, let's
just let's say I've decided I want to do
this parasite cleanse. So, my
recommendation is you start doing the GI
cleanse now. And you do the GI cleanse
up until the day before, the day of, and
the day after the full moon.
That gets many of the parasites out to
start with, but then you do the
aggressive program at the time of the
full moon. And then my recommendation is
you consider continue with that GI
cleanse three times a day every day
after you've done that aggressive
protocol until the next full moon. Now,
I am of the opinion that we should do it
through three full moon cycles. Why do I
say that? I say that because of our
understanding of parasites. When we talk
about parasites, we have eggs, we have
the larvae, and we have the adult mature
parasites. Normally when you do the
cleanse, you're going to get the mature
parasites. But what happens is so
oftenimes because these larvae and eggs
are so deeply embedded in the colon or
wherever they take up residence
sometimes you don't get them the first
time around but they then have the
opportunity to become mature.
So the second goound you're going to be
cleaning out the mature adults once
again.
And then I always say a third goound,
mostly because when we talk about those
eggs that have not become larvae that
then turn into the mature adults, let's
just make sure we've gotten it all. And
so that's my approach. That's the way I
suggest that the protocol should be
done. And like I said, I've had very
good results. People have reported back
to me things that perhaps I didn't want
to know about, but it's part of what we
have to do to get ourselves cleaned out
and keep ourselves healthy.
And I like the fact that you are
encouraging people to be
consistent
because oops, consistency in all things
is important.
>> Consistency in your 90, consistency in
making sure that you're, you know,
keeping track of what's going in your
body to help control blood sugar. And
now we know parasites, too.
>> Oh, yeah. And parasites can cause cause
blood sugar issues. Interestingly
enough, you know, people don't think
about it, but when we talk about the the
symptoms that are associated with
parasites, like I said, it's a long
list. And blood sugar issues can be part
of it because oftentimes when people
have parasites, they have wicked sugar
cravings
>> and they can't seem to satisfy that
sugar craving no matter what they do.
And so when people have sugar cravings,
it may in fact be because they have
parasites.
>> Oh, good thing to think about folks. So
we do have a couple more questions. One,
would you use the GI cleanse topically?
>> Well, you can use the GI cleanse
topically, but in this case, it's better
if you use it internally. And again,
oftentimes we're going after parasites
that are in the gastrointestinal system.
And it's going to work better on those
parasites if you take it internally. And
again, it should be on an empty stomach.
Now, some people say, "Woo, I just don't
like the taste." Mix it with a little
bit of water. Don't worry about the
taste. The other thing that I'll say
about the good herb good herbs products
as a general rule
because the extraction of the herbs the
the best extraction process includes
alcohol and it's excuse me a high
quality alcohol but a lot of people
don't want to consume alcohol in any way
shape or form. I respect that. What I
tell people is if that's the case, take
your dose. So, I'm going to take three
darpers full. Take that dose of the Good
Herbs product, put it into a small
glass, and leave it on the counter for
at least 6 to 8 hours.
The reason for that is in that amount of
time, your alcohol will evaporate and
you'll be left strictly with the herbs.
So just
I always encourage people to do that if
they you know oh I can't use the herbs
because the herbs have been extracted
and processed with the alcohol and I
can't do alcohol.
I respect that there are people out
there who do not will not use alcohol
and I I'm very respectful of that. But
that's one way that we can get around
it. Allow that alcohol to evaporate off
the product before you take it. But with
most of these products, you can take
them and you can mix them and you can do
all those things. The GI cleanse is not
that product. The GI cleanse usually we
say do it on an empty stomach. It's best
because what you're doing with that GI
cleanse is you're going after the
parasites.
>> Excellent. Thank you so much. We've got
a couple more questions. Now Lenny
writes in and he says, "Live blood cell
analysis showed a pinworm in my blood.
Can pinworms cause chronic anemia?
>> Yes.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. That's I mean that's that's a yes
or no question. So yes, Lenny, pinw
worms can cause chronic anemia. And Jill
is wanting to know, "What about sty
cysts around the eyelids that don't go
away for months no matter what you try
holistically?"
>> I would definitely try the cleanse. I
would definitely try the cleanse. If you
are someone who has that problem and
you've tried everything that we know
that normally would work,
>> what are we left with? There's got to be
a cause. There's got to be a reason. So,
let's consider that it might be
parasites. I certainly wouldn't hesitate
to do that.
>> All right. And Charmaine,
forgive me because I don't know if I'm
going to say this correctly. What about
someone who has ilio ectomy?
>> Okay.
>> I l e o s t o m y.
>> Okay. So, ilostomy. Okay.
>> All right. Those people should also they
should consider taking it. Okay. An
ilostomy means that the things that come
out of their body don't come out through
the anus and into the toilet like they
normally would. Okay, they come out
through a bag on the side of a person's
abdomen. Okay, so because of that I well
I would still say try taking that
parasite cleanse
orally by mouth but in that particular
case then that's when a person may in
fact want to do it topically.
>> Okay. If you're going to do it
topically,
>> yeah, if you're going to do it
topically, I would recommend that you
rub it on the bottoms of your feet. We
know that these products are very well
absorbed through the bottoms of the
feet. And the recommendation for the
Good Herbish products, if you're going
to use them on the bottoms of the feet,
you apply some of the solution to the
bottom of your foot and it will be
absorbed relatively quickly. You
continue to apply it, and we're not
talking about a lot, okay? But you
continue to apply it until it stays damp
or wet on the bottom of your foot. And
that tells you that your body has taken
in what it needs for that particular
dose.
>> So I'll use like a spritz bottle.
I'll have it in in a little Boston
bottle with the the sprayer. Does that
work?
>> It can absolutely. If it if you've got
one in there, if what you have in there
is the pure good herbs product. Yes.
Yes, that and nothing else.
>> Yep.
>> Excellent. Now, um
Nancy wants to know, "What is the active
ingredient in the cleanse?" So, it's a
combination, isn't it?
>> Oh, it's a combination of products, but
in the GI cleanse, you've got the
wormwood, you've got um walnut, you've
got the other things that we know.
You've got clove, the other things that
we know that are specific for getting
those parasites.
>> All right. Thank you so much. And one
more question, Marilyn,
go ahead.
>> Um, I had heard Dr. um, actually Brett
Bushwati, I don't know if he's a doctor
or not, but he said that sometimes you
want the alcohol to help bypass the
digestive system so you get better
absorption.
>> Correct.
>> That true?
>> Yes. Yes. Oh, hey, anything that Brett
says is true. when it when it comes to
the good herbs products, anything that
he says is true. But yes, absolutely
that's true. But again, there are people
who just flat won't do alcohol, don't
want to do alcohol.
>> And why is it And why is that? How is it
that the alcohol uh allows the product
to bypass? How is that? Do you know
>> how it allows it to bypass? No, I don't
know exactly the mechanism for how that
works.
>> He went into it. I just can't remember.
>> Yeah. No, and I would have to ask him
again. He's going to be on my call again
and one time this month and so I'll make
sure I ask that question.
>> Fantastic. Thank you.
>> All right. Fantastic. And if I could get
the other co-hosts up on the screen with
us. I'm so thankful, Dr. Joanne Conway,
we don't have to do this all by
ourselves as we have some amazing talent
as we're coming together to pre create
this resource that we are able to share
with the world. And that's sharing you
with the world. Folks, if you got more
or have questions that or you want to
know more about Dr. Joanne Conway, you
can go to her website
djconway,
c a wy.com.
And don't forget to get her book.
Absolutely love her book. In fact,
no, I'm not going to do that.
>> Okay. I have I have well I have a case
of your books and I still have some to
share. So I thought about doing a
giveaway but maybe next time. Maybe next
time. Um but yeah make sure that you get
Dr. Conaway's book folks as it is
amazing. The title of it is Why Is
America So Sick by Dr. Joanne Conaway.
Um,
and Alexandria wants to know, "Is the
mentioned print out available?" Yes, it
is. You want to email questions at
dailywithdoc.com
requesting the duo.
What do you call
>> dynamic duo? Dynamic
>> dynamic duo.
>> Parasite cleanse
>> um protocol. The parasite cleanse. So
that's where you do go to get that
questions at dailywithdoc.com.
And Dr. Conway, I know you got a hard
stop. So
we have an amazing team. I'm super
excited that we are able to host
individuals like Dr. Joanne Conaway as
she is bringing her experience, her
knowledge and she has a call every
Tuesday night. So if folks if you would
like information about that, you can
also email questions at
dailywithdoc.com.
We will reply with um information on how
to access her call that she does. And
and Dr. Conway you have slide
presentations and everything on those
calls. So not only if somebody is you
know good at learning just by listening
those that want to see something and
learn better that way. Absolutely. For
those of you who are here in the live
Zoom with us that information is in the
chat. one of the great reasons and to be
here live with us um as we're here
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday from 12 to
100 p.m. Pacific, 1 to 2 mountain, 2 to
3 central, 3 to 4 Eastern. And if in
your if you're in South Africa,
I think that's 9 to 10. Give me a heads
up. Yes or no? 9 to 10 to 11. 10 to 10
to 11 at the moment.
>> 10 to 11 p.m. in South Africa. Thank you
so much. And that is Albert. He is like
our gatekeeper letting people into the
Zoom. We have Marilyn and Phyllis both
doing a fantastic job putting
information into the chat. We have
Sherry and Phyllis keeping an eye and um
AJ keeping an eye on the different
platforms.
So, thank you. so much everybody for
joining us here on Daily with Doc. My
name is Becca Dukes. And if you are
interested in getting more information
and becoming a certified holistic health
coach like everybody that's on the
screen, I think you're even a certified
holistic health coach, Dr. Joanne
Conaway.
>> The first goound.
>> Yes. We took it together.
>> Yep.
>> I love it. Love it. Love it. And now
it's even bigger and better, folks.
coach.ailywithdoc.com.
If there's nobody that sent you to this
program, if there is, ask them if they
know anything about the certified
holistic health coach course as they may
have their own link, but if not,
coach.dwithdoc.com.
So, we'll see you tomorrow. Thank you
again everybody for joining us. Oh,
Sherry. Sherry's part of our techn tech
crew, so she's keeping an eye on things,
making sure that the streams are going
out and they have sound. So, thank you
so much, Sher, for doing that. Folks,
until next time. Bye for now.
Thank you. Thank you, everybody.
And have
>> [music]
[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding [music] health or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor [music] of Science in Plant and
Soil Sciences, Doctor of Veterary
Medicine, Ford post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.